muss man sich mal vorstellen man denkt
sich einfach nichts da kommt so eine
person an fact einfach im internet und
versucht mit den eigenen bildern
irgendwie mädels aufzureißen oder
vielleicht wieder aufreißen keine ahnung
was er vorhat
service kids und herzlich willkommen zu
einem neuen video in dem ich euch heute
mal die geschichte von jan erzählen
möchte mich jetzt bestimmt wer es jan
jan ist ein 18 jahre alter junge
vielleicht manche würden sagen gut
aussehen andere würden sagen behindert
aber dieser jan hat nur eine
besonderheit wirklichkeit ist er nicht
jan sondern ich so jetzt ist die große
frage was heißt das wieso ist ja nich
wie kommen die beiden persönlichkeiten
zusammen leute es ist folgendermaßen ich
habe einen fake auflage der sich mit
meinen bildern auf lavaux als jan
ausgibt jan 18 jahre alt und da versucht
irgendwie mit meinen bildern mein fotos
von instagram irgendwie mädels zu klären
und das ist an sich schon eine relativ
starke nummer würde ich sagen
davon möchte ich heute erzählen wie bin
ich da drauf gekommen
eine zuschauerin von mir hat mir auf
twitter geschrieben die liebe sarah
dankeschön sarah für den hinweis hat mir
geschrieben
das ist doch wohl so einen typen gibt
der mich aufregt und ich dachte mir so
wichtig so fade mich jemand auf lamu und
dann hat sie mir so bilder geschickt und
ich dachte echt ich blieb aus weil es
einfach so mega dreist wie kommt man
darauf einfach bilder von einem youtuber
oder von sonst irgendeiner person zu
stehlen und sich als diese person
auszugeben
vor allem weil dieser jan einfach noch
extrem kindlich schreibt also wirklich
alt kniff er so nicht sein tag der
checkpoint da hab ich mich gerade what
the [ __ ] und leute ich habe überlegt ich
habe überlegt ob ich da vielleicht krank
anruf machen sollte weil der gute seine
handynummer im profil stehen hat aber
das ging leider nicht er war nicht
erreichbar auf seinem handy das wäre der
absolute burner gewesen man da so in
verruf gemacht hätte
ich hätte einfach so getan als hätte ich
seine mutter fallen so als hätte ich
eine nummer darauf nabu gesehen und wer
halt irgendwie interessiert
als dann noch mal das modul hat mir
gerade eben schon ist wirklich zweimal
hintereinander das gleiche modell jetzt
gerade weil das habe ich noch nie
gesehen
so aber vielmehr dass man plant hätte
ich gesagt entweder ich hätte es
irgendwie hinbekommen mich als frau
auszugeben in der weiblichen stimme oder
irgend eine freundin von mir darum zu
bitten ihn anzurufen und zu fragen hey
was soll ich bilder von ex kämmerin so
dass wir ganz herzlich gewesen auch oder
ich hätte es so gemacht dass ich so
getan hätte als welche die wird es über
die kommentarschreiber habt ihr eure
bescherung und dann hätte ich einfach so
also inhalt bisschen verarbeitete so
getan als wenn schulen als wäre ich
irgendwie so an ihm interessiert und er
würde so gut aussehen keine hanno glaube
das war richtig witzig geworden aber es
ging leider nicht
aber leute ich hab auch noch tatsächlich
bilder als allererstes jetzt mal hier
diesen check point nehmen und hier ein
bild von jan slawo profil so sieht das
aus also so fällt er mich mit meinen
bildern auf lamu ziemlich starke nummer
muss man sagen finde ich sehr sehr
dreist also dass es viel verändert reist
er in aktion die ich im internet erlebt
habe sagt nein es hat mich erreicht ach
schade wäre so schön gewesen so first
try durchgebrannt und dann hat er
benannte sarah die mich darauf
hingewiesen hat in meinem auftrag den
mal angeschrieben weil ich irgendwann
auch über sarah herausgekommen war ob
aus der luft heraus bekommen wollte wie
man den vielleicht doch anrufen kann im
burger hin und her und sarah hat ein
bisschen dem geschrieben und hat ihn
dann auch darauf angesprochen dass er
wohl bilder von youtube in seinem labor
profil verwendet und er hat relativ
dreist wieder mal geantwortet also der
junge zeichnet sich durch absolute
dreistigkeit aus kommt jetzt kurz hier
sehr schön ich guck mal die kurze
trümpler geöffnet so dass auch sie erst
mal kurz meine twitter-nachrichten müsst
euch nachzuschauen genau sie schreibt
ihm hh dunst von youtube und er so n ein
fragezeichen
also lieber jan oder wie immer du in
wirklichkeit heißt wenn du das hier
liest ganz schön ganz schön dreist von
dir wirklich ganz schön dreist und ich
würde vielleicht raten das profil zu
löschen beziehungsweise der bilder von
jemanden zu suchen denen es nicht stört
weil ich einfach unfassbar creepy finde
dass leute meine bilder clown sich damit
im internet ausgeben als
anders zu sein folgen jahren was ist jan
für rendel name ich bin kein jan ich bin
sebastian vielleicht noch eines kfd aber
auf jeden fall kein ja also ich lasse
mich auch hier ja nie sieren er scheint
man so eng nei und sie so auch so aber
warum heißt du hier jan und also ja weil
ihn mit zwei namen jan heiße und freunde
mich mit jan ansprechen
alles klar ich heiße also sebastian jan
und meine freunde spreche mich mit
jahren an
gut zu wissen will ich so leute ab jetzt
könnt ihr mich alle ja nennen
zumindest alle die dieses video sehen
haben dann einfach so ein insider
in dem sinne ja nennen aber jackpot was
ist das was ist das was ist das für eine
schwarze magie die blöcke sind
unsichtbar bot das ist dass man herford
die fahrkarte hier sag ich so a ha große
ausnahme
what the [ __ ] das ist dass man das ist
wirklich schwarze magie unsichtbare
blöcke in jump league also ihr steps
wirklich aufs nächste level und dann
hatte ich irgendwie sarah um die
geschichte mal weiterhin 14
sala das ganz schön schwer da
hinzukommen gebeten da irgendwie doch an
die nummer ranzukommen wir mit diesem
projekt anruf machen wollte und dann hat
sich das folgende ergeben ich schaue da
mal wieder in den nachrichten für euch
wenn ich den sprung erzieher erfolgreich
verpackt habe aber habe ich doch gleich
so okay da ist schon mal unsere kiste
deswegen nehme ich erst bisschen weiter
dass mit halten ein
da kommt dann schon sprung am ende sorry
für das wort aber wie gemein was für ein
gemeinde sprung die perfide kann man
sein so einem abzubauen leute aber die
anderen sind auch nicht viel weiter als
ich was mache ich hier kurz mal easy
kulturen direkt drauf gesprungen über
macht es kurz noch fertig machen weiter
in der geschichte mit den bildern sehr
schön
sie falten dann so hast du lust
telefonieren also ja kann leider nicht
telefonieren
mein handy spinnt und nimmt diesen nicht
mal mehr an ein skype habe ich leider
nicht ts hatte er natürlich auch nicht
natürlich schade aber würde ich auch so
machen wenn ich mich als jemand anders
ausgehen würde würde ich auch so tun als
gebe es keine möglichkeit mir wirklich
zu reden denn hier und jetzt habe ich
auch nichts süßes schreibt mir dann so
richtig gysi der junge und dann habe nur
noch whatsapp und da kann man sprach
nachrichten schicken
und ich habe auch die ein oder andere
sprachnachricht tatsächlich hier fällt
mir jetzt gerade ein
ich muss mal gucken vielleicht baue ich
die am ende des videos 1 noch mal eine
sprachnachricht damit wir alle uns mal
anhören können habe ich übrigens selbst
noch nicht gemacht wie dieser jahren
denn so drauf ist und wie mein
persönlicher ruf egger einfach redet
kanal wie alt er ist er kann eigentlich
nicht so alt sein
also schreibt als hätte irgendwie
schwere lrs nodes respekt ging alle
leidenden aber hier kommt der region
mitnehmen liste kiste kiste kiste kiste
oh ja ja ja oh geil ich hab alles
mitbekommt sehr schön
pam pam pam pam es gibt also ist alles
in allem schon relativ kasse story aber
da es ja kann man ja mal hätten hier
aber dass irgendwo man youtube account
betrifft und vielleicht ich hoffe es
nicht aber vielleicht irgend jemand von
euch bereits darauf ein gefallen ist
oder noch darauf reinfallen könnte ich
heiße nicht an
solltet ihr eigentlich wissen aber das
ist ein fehler von mir
und ja es ist einfach krass muss man
sich mal vorstellen man denkt sich
einfach nichts da kommt so eine person
anfängt einen einfach im internet und
versucht mit den eigenen bildern
irgendwie mädels aufzureißen oder
vielleicht auch typen aufweisen keine
ahnung was er vorhat aber es ist einfach
krass so jetzt mal kurz durchatmen
soweit thema wohl abgang wird sagen die
machen jetzt mal hier an die party
james blake jetzt hat er bekommen du
alter schlinger du dich jetzt erst mal
down down media aber ihnen stand da und
sage ich hatte hier das und das und das
und das alter sehr schön alles
mitbekommen
der kompass tag in die richtung
leute ich habe vier level wo ist der
nächste fucking entstand hat guckt euch
das an bauer setzt sich nicht durch
moment weit weg von uns getroffen
da ist er und zack come on come on come
on in deinem kopf nein schwert sackgasse
wie krass ich treffe einfach nicht gut
gelaufen muss ich aber sagen ja das habe
ich nämlich einmal okay für mich rein wo
ich mit den oder den komfort einer drauf
aber hat nun hatten heute ist es gar
nichts wissen bessere rüstung als man
erwarten würde für eine holz axt aber er
hat auch nichts und ich habe jetzt schon
14 pfeile
ich weiß gar nicht ob ich jemals so
viele feilen und deathmatch hatte aber
leute eine sache noch zu der geschichte
mich interessiert was ihr davon haltet
was sagt ihr zu dieser geschichte zu
dieser wirklich creeping stalker faker
internet geschichte schreibt es einfach
mal die kommentare
ich habe mir erst mal sogar so what the
[ __ ] und dann hab ich mir gedacht wenn
mich jemand fragt kann ich eigentlich
auch selbst ein original profil auch
machen und moment mal leider sieht jetzt
so aus als als 80 mache dann mache ich
natürlich nicht und das beweis ich indem
ich jetzt sage davos scheiße besorgt
euch auf keinen fall das gerät einfach
nicht weiter darüber was mache ich denn
irgendwann so ok kurz ein bisschen ab
stöhnen know it's okay kommt ihr über
bist du denn mein darling senator lp ist
es der mit dem loh equipment ja das ist
er mit dem jörg widmann
ob gott der wird versuchen wegzulaufen
wo gott es wird eine abfallgrube leute
ich sie es kommt das wird ein abverkauf
senator rp komme ich wenig weg du willst
dich in sicherheit aber du bist nicht
wählen deswegen hast du keine chance
spitzenreiter erst dann noch kommen nur
noch ein kill don't run away
ich will nicht wehtun ich will einfach
nur gegen dich kämpfen und diese runde
hier ganz glatt beenden und er spielt
jetzt auf sieg oder worauf spielt er
eigentlich wenn der weg läuft
nein mach nicht wie gebiet gebiet der
juni mit drauf machnig pro machnig
broder geht er ein sehr schön dass es
überhaupt nicht klug von ihm aber das
heißt nicht klug ist vielleicht nicht
das flugs und lange zu überleben aber
das fairste so leute wie gesagt eure
meinung in die kommentare lassen
wir sehen uns wieder haut rein macht's
gut